how are they increase that probably
many are they that rise up against me
many that they would save my soul
there is no help for him in god
but thou o lord under shield for me
my glory
and the lifter up of my head
i cried into the lord with my voice
and he heard me
out of his holy hill
i laid me down and slept
i wait
for the lord sustained me
i will not be afraid of ten thousands of
people that have set themselves against
me round about
arise o lord save me o my god
for thou has spit all my enemies upon
the cheekbone thou has broken the teeth
of the ungodly
salvation belongeth unto the lord
thy blessing
is upon my people amen god is good
and all the
[Music]
uh good time
everyone good afternoon good afternoon
everyone
how are you
come to the end of this blessed weekend
time really flying very quickly
but god is in
control one of the lessons i get from
the fact that time flies quickly
is that if you have something to do
do it
you know when i'm studying
or preparing a sermon i have learned a
hard way
if god brings something to my mind
act on it immediately
or god will take it away
so guys i'm preaching very often i'm
preaching
and the lord tells me say this
and i decide to let me finish this
sentence first yes
then i'll say that
by the time i finish the sentence
that is gone
then in the sermon quietly i have to
apologize to god
so when god
brings something to you
act on it
immediately
whatever the conviction may be
but i'm happy to see you
god bless you
i have been highly blessed
i keep writing my friends tell them how
blessed i am
to be here and how i'm enjoying the
fellowship
with god's children in this part of his
world the entire world belongs to god
amen so
and i met this young lady and she was
one of those making sure i was all right
i was using two weeks and she said to me
we're chatting i'd like to visit your
country
but it's so hard to get a visa
i said ask god amen
this is my father's world
ask god
where she looked at me as though i
hadn't taken my medication that day
and i said ask god
obey him and ask him
the bible says delight thyself also in
the lord and he shall give thee
the desires of thy heart
this is no joke
so i finished my assignments in orlando
eats delightful two weeks way back home
about four weeks later i got an email
from her
she said pastor
i got the visa
and she got it just in time to pretend
in gc there was a gc somewhere in the
united states
so the lord
will give you the desires of your heart
all he asks
oh baby
and if you listen to my servant you know
my favorite word is obey
do what god tells you
the way he tells you do not offer
recommendations to god
[Music]
do not modify what god has said
as my dear sisters so honestly confessed
and another sister
they marry me outside of the church
and i have run into so many of god's
daughters who made that decision
consciously
to marry outside the church
and
almost invariably
you paid a painful price
despite your arguments that he was a
good baptist
and he was the nephew of the pope and
all the other arguments we use
to justify burying outside of the church
when you violate god's way you pay the
consequence are you listening to me it
is not my message but i wanted to get
that through we have to learn
the simple concept
do
what god tells you
as he tells you you know in john chapter
two but let me say let me pray father
this is not my servant and i don't want
to talk long without seeking your
guidance give me wisdom please in jesus
name amen
when jesus was at the marriage feast in
cana
the mother said to him
in verse 3 of john 2
the bible says when they wanted why the
mother of jesus said unto him
they have no wine
jesus said unto the woman
what have i to do with thee my power is
not yet come
mary didn't respond to that she just
turned to the surface in verse 5 and she
said to them
whatsoever he said unto you
do it
amen
now do you need a phd from western
[Music]
province university is this a university
called western promise
of cape town let's use that do you need
a degree from that school to understand
whatsoever he said unto you
somebody said
no matter what says we have a different
god says give me a tithe
from your
increase
and we want to give it from our net
god says i want from the increase
god says the sun plays the sabbath we
say what about the first
god says one has not one wife say what
about one husband two wives
for everything god tells us we seem to
have a human recommendation which always
leads on the path to disaster my friends
my brothers in christ
if you want to live and live a life that
is largely
problem free
do what god says
at all times
under all circumstances
exactly as he tells you
do not modify it
i have to say that
and that's
that anyone with us for the very first
time this weekend you are not assembling
the advertisement notice your hand
first time
you're not oh
would you kindly stand
please
good afternoon
what is your name
my name is convo your name is one
cornwall cornwall that's right
and
the lady next team
roxanne
how are you
nice to see what's the name of the baby
my name is michaela michaela yes how old
is michaela
three months god bless michaela
all that he blesses you but i want him
to bless you too may god bless you
is this a family yeah we are a family
okay well god bless you thanks for
coming who invited you
our good friends ah it's good to have
good friends the best friend you can
have is jesus thank you very much we're
honored by your presence i may not bless
your life
provide your needs protect you from harm
and danger and will all protect the kill
from childhood diseases and from every
other day through this society as she
grows up and lives a safe and blessed
life say amen to our friends
say it again
one more time
god is good
and all the time
you see how much we like you god bless
you
yes my good brother how are you
what's your name
isaac
who was isaac's wife
rebecca nice to have you
i said where are you from originally
where
is that
okay who invited you isaac
your brother is a good man
brother brother thank you very much
for inviting isaac
it again
one more time
god is good
all the time
how many of you love god and it's your
hair
god is happy
god loves to be told i love you i say
god bless you
thank you very much for coming you may
be seated my handsome brother anyone
else you are not the second diabetes
you are here for the first time
all right
it is now
25 after 12 i will do everything in my
power my limited power to release you by
uh one
that's okay saying that
but if the spirit tells me to go live
okay let me uh
irritate you what's this
what's that
where are we
in church
what do you think i'd prefer you to use
but if this is all you have make sure it
does not ring are you following me all
right when you go to a banquet
a formal occasion
do you dress a certain way
yes come on don't hesitate yes
do you want sneakers to battle
no when you wear a tuxedo you wear brown
shoes
no you wear black shoes are you calling
me
or when you're in church
you should do things differently
[Music]
the second truth i ask is that you pray
for me while i'm speaking
and all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in my mouth
and these are god's words and i that's
what i want to come out of my mouth and
the direction of god's spirit
if you pray that praying
god will answer because that prayer is
100 his will and he has assured us in
first john 5
14 and this is the confidence that we
have in him that if we ask anything
according to his will
he hears us
and phil number three
i'd like you very much to think as you
listen isaiah 1 18 come now
let us reason together
said the lord
let's borrow hands and pray
holy father
we are alive because of your mercy
not because of vitamins
or supplements
as good as they are
we thank lord for clear minds
to receive the word
to think about it
and to be led to the correct conclusions
under the guidance of your spirit
father as we assemble in your presence i
ask in the name of jesus forgive us if
we sin against you
because the only problem we have is sin
cleanses their god
because with the removal of sin
understanding spiritual things becomes
easier
i humble myself in your presence
because i'm a human being and god it is
easy for me to engage in self-exaltation
but i do not want to do that father
and so i give you 100 permission
suppress my car of nature
that the holy spirit may have no
hindrance as he tries to use it
tell me what to say
tell me when to say
tell me how to say it
a very special blessing dear god on our
guests who've come to be with us
touch their lives they've done in such a
way that they will know
that the almighty has moved in their
lives
now dear god
at the end of this service
let us know we have heard from you not
from me
i offer this prayer in jesus name with
ultimate request
that you bless this nation
and every mission represented by this
congregation
in jesus name let god be the same amen
and
our subject
right action
wrong motif what did i say
wrong movie genesis one reading from
first one
genesis one reading from verse one
we could find an easier text to find
genesis one by the way that's my
favorite version
you should have to look you
[Music]
and the spirit of god
moved upon the face of the waters
and god said
let there be light
and there was light
and god saw the light
that it was good
and god divided the light from the
darkness
and god called the light day in the
darkness of all night
and the evening in the morning
for the first day
you look at first one again
in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
let's add to that colossians chapter 1
verse 16
colossians 1 verse 16
for by him
were all things created
that are in heaven
and then out of earth
visible and invisible
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were
created by him and for him
and he is before all things and by him
all things consist
so we read again that god made
everything psalm 33 verse 6
by the word of the lord with heaven's
name and all the host of them by the
breath of his mouth hebrews 11 3
through faith we understand that the
worlds are framed by the word of god
what i'm trying to stress
god
made
everything amen
let's go to genesis one will be from
first semester let's itemize
our subject
right action
wrong motif
genesis 1 verse 11 the bible says and
god said live earth bring forth grass
the earth seed
and the fruity yielding fruit after his
kind who seizes himself upon the earth
and it was so and the earth brought from
grass all right that's meditation
when god made vegetation god at the same
time put into place all the laws of
nature required for vegetation to
flourish the laws that govern
photosynthesis began to operate the
instant god created vegetation
when god made the light
the laws that govern the behavior of
photons began to function as soon as the
light was made
are you with me
if you go down to verse 20
and god said let the waters bring forth
abundantly the moving creature that have
life and fatherly fire of the earth in
the open firmament of heaven when god
made the birds god instantly put into
operation the laws of physics that allow
birds to fly
when god made the dry land the second
day and separated it from the water god
put into that creation the laws that
govern trilat the lust lost that nothing
water what am i trying to say
every branch of knowledge
covered by the heavens
and the earth
came
from god
[Music]
let me say it again
astronomy
originated with god
genesis 1 14 and god said
let me be light in the firmament of the
heaven to divine the day from the night
and let them be for signs of the seasons
and for days and years and let them be
for light in the firmament of the heaven
to give light upon the earth and it was
so and god made two great lives the
greater like to rule the day and the
lessons like to rule the night he made
the stars also we have sun moon stars
our galaxy astronomy originated with god
amen
botany
originated
with god
verse 24 and god said
let the earth bring forth the living
creature after his sky cattle and
dreaming faith and peace of the earth
after his kind and it was so and god
made the beast of the earth after his
time and cattle after their eye and
everything that created upon the earth
after his eye zoology
god said
let us make man
in our image
anthropology originated with god biology
originated with god
physics is part of life the study of
life is part of physics that originated
with god what am i trying to say
the fear of the lord
is the beginning
of knowledge
i'm taking this approach because many of
you are college students or
contemplating attending college or
you've already graduated and want to go
one step higher hopefully before jesus
comes
the christian student
studies
with a different motivation
when god made heaven the earth
god made it
for his glory
let me
say that differently
everything god created
was created
for his glory
psalm 19 verse 1 you know it very well
the heavens declare come on the glory of
god and the firmament truth is handiwork
we have handiwork and we have glory
the artistry of god his heavy work can
be seen in the heavenly bodies of the
night
any day of the week
any time you look at the right time
certain bodies are in the same place all
the time are you following them if that
were the case
mammograms cannot navigate at night in
ships particularly in those days when we
did not have refined instruments the
heavens declare the glory of god
this is a god who is orderly
[Music]
this is a god who is
systematic
this is a god who values
beauty
this is a god who focuses on
detail the heavens declared his glory
and refurbishment his handiwork
romans 1 20
for the invisible face of god or him
from the creation of the world are
clearly seen
let me say that again
the invisible things of him
from the creation of the world
are clearly seen
clearly see
where
being understood by the things that are
made
heaven on earth even his eternal power
and godhead so that they are without
excuse
we always make excuses for the heathen
in the jungle who never knows god
there's no such thing as i never know
god
there's generally no such thing as a
devil or god
every tree is evidence of god
every bird is evidence of god
the sky is evidence of god's presence
that's why the bible says the invisible
things of him his essential
characteristics from the foundation of
the creation of the world are clearly
seen
being understood
by the things
that are made
which means if i am studying now
physiology
or anatomy
and i learned that
the shoulder muscle
move the upper arm
the upper arm moves the lower
and the muscles of the tendon in the
lower arm
move this
and i realize the same thing works from
here down and i ask myself
this is
order
system
this is not accidental are you with me
no i may not know the name god
but i must honestly conclude there is a
power behind this
when the child of god studies whatever
it is
our subject is wrong right actually
the motive for study is not agreed
it's a discovery of god
is this microphone working
the motive for studying
is to discover god
if you do that with all your heart
the great will come
i want to uh
read about science
and more
by any stretch of the imagination but
i'd love to read about it i want to
study the bible
because i'm looking for god's
fingerprints
i'm looking for his footprints
you see every artist has a style now if
you study music you can identify
mozart's work
from handheld
or medicine
or beethoven
if you're an artist you paint and
whatever else you know this is monday
this is van gogh no this is picasso they
have styles that you see the style comes
into what you do without your conscious
control
you can read a book
this is that offer
this point this sounds like wordsworth
or you want yourself
you know
he made that film
the sacrifice to god god's style
is in his creation amen
and so the bible says the heavens
declare the glory of god and the
firmament of this adwords the glory of
god being the captain of god before any
further let me pray again father come
continue to speak through me to god very
very clearly and let me not get in the
way of your communication
in jesus name
amen all of the heavens declare god's
girl fine
let's go to isis six
our subject right action which is family
wrong motive which is a grave
your primary motive must be to discover
god
the greatest second then
isaiah 6 reading from verse 1
you have isaiah 6 1
what did you say
let's read
in the year the king as i died
i saw also the
saved upon the throne high lifted up and
his train filled the temple
above it stood the same thing
each one had six wings
with twain he covered his face
and with three he covered his feet and
with two heated fly
verse three down
read it microscopically and one cry unto
another and say what do you say
holy
holy holy is the lord of hosts finish
the verse
psalm 91
what is psalm 91 saying
the heavens declare the glory of god
so the entire atmosphere the entire
cosmos
reflects god
the bible also says the whole earth
is full of his glory
in the beginning
god created
the heavens
and the earth
anywhere you go you're either on earth
or in heaven
[Music]
the bible speaks in three heavens
the heavenly goddess
the heaven where the sun who stars and
other constellations are
and the health universe fly in our
atmosphere
anywhere you go in this universe
you're either in heaven
or earth
now
why do i say that
you cannot get away
from god amen
which means the greatest act of denying
is the act of an atheist to say
there is no god
why he or she is surrounded by all the
evidence of god
the heavens explain god's glory
the earth is full of his glory
god has arranged that lord can miss the
fact that there is a superior being
so i say again
when you study physiology
don't study first for agree
study
to discover god because god evidences of
god can be discovered in every branch of
knowledge child guidance page 45
paragraph three
the whole natural world is designed to
be an interpreter of the things of god
amen
i'll give you that quotation again
listen microscopically there's a word i
want you to focus on
the whole
natural world
is designed to be an interpreter of the
things of god when you hear design
you don't purposeful
god
deliberately place evidence of himself
in his creation the whole
natural world the bible says go to the
end thou slow
consider always and be wise in other
words let nature
[Music]
or termites and determined whatever
and you can learn lessons
jesus said
therefore i say to you take your
thoughts for your life what you shall
eat
and what you shall drink
not yet for your body what you shall put
on
is not the life more than meat and the
body than the ribbon matthew 6 25 and i
go to 26 now behold the fouls of the air
that's not symbolic
look at them
study them on mythology behold the fouls
of the air they saw not neither do they
reap nor gather to mars yet your
heavenly father feels dead you look at
birds as god see how they're provided
for and you tell me if i provide for
birds for whom i did not die will i not
provide for you
consider the lilies and field how they
grow
you cannot consider something in a flat
take time watch the plants growing in
your garden and understand i will do
that for you to a high degree because i
did not make plans in my image i need
you
the fear of the lord
is the beginning of knowledge
proverbs 9 10. the fear of the lord
is the beginning of wisdom
from oneself
if knowledge is the accumulation of
facts
start with god
if wisdom is the application of that
knowledge stuff with god
which drives me to this conclusion
in god's arrangement
the purpose of education is not to get a
job
it is to get to know god
let me rephrase to put your minds at
rest
the primary purpose of education
is not to get a job
and i'm not shocked that no one said
amen
[Music]
because of the reconditioned by society
the problem i am giving you heaven's
perspective that's where i think you're
planning to go
well only this week is better
the primary purpose of work of study
is to earn
a knowledge of god
let me tell you something else
go to genesis 2 15.
right actually wrong
genesis 2 15 we just discovered the
primary purpose of education is to know
god not to get a job
genesis 2 15
are you there
are you married with me if you held my
first the king james and the lord wanted
the man and put him in the garden of
eden to dress it and to eat it in that
verse what did god give to adam
to work
work
but there was no salary
the primary purpose of work
is not to earn money
but to develop account
and i said primarily to put your mind on
this the money comes right after that as
you understand the primary purpose of
work is counter development
the primary purpose of education is to
know god
now
when you sit in a classroom studying
chemistry
which is a time of trouble for medicines
and your motive is no god
it changes your attitude towards cancer
and i guarantee you
if you search for god with all your
heart in chemistry
[Music]
the heavens declare the glory of god
we must have said that as a fact
the whole earth is full of his glory
which means god has
filled all of creation
with
unmistakable evidence of this presence
you see before sin
the book of instruction was not the
bible
there was nobody
there was no need the book of
instruction finished my words was
nature
that was god's plan for instructing
admiral
nature
this is this quotation you'll find
difficult to believe
um
paycheck is prophesied no education
page 45 paragraph four i think it is it
was
in both the with both the animate and
the inanimate creation
with leaf
and flower and tree
and with every living creature from the
leviathan in waters to the moat in the
sun being
the dwellers in eden held converse
gathering to reach
the secrets of its life
let me put it
in sunset west english
before sin
i believe
learn how a leaf function directly from
the lead
they could communicate
how i don't know
because of sin we lost so much
we lost so much
with both the enemy and the inanimate
creation
with leaf and flower and tree
and with every living thing or creature
from the leviathan of the waters to the
remote in the sun being the dwellers in
eden hell converse
converse
gathering from each
the secrets
of its
life it has always been god's desire
that by the study of nature
we would learn and learn and learn and
learn of god
child guidance page 46 paragraph three
in the natural world
god has placed in the hands of the
children of men
the key to unlock the treasure house of
his word
the unseen
is illustrated by the same
divine wisdom
eternal truth
infinite grace are undisturbed
by the things that god has made
you didn't get that
divine wisdom
infinite truth
eternal truth and infinite grace all can
be understood
by studying the things that god has made
[Music]
and i'm taking this of course as i said
because many of you study
god judges an action
by the motive
christ object lesson speech 360. i don't
have to every act is judged by the
quotient
you know
the bible says the curse causing it
shall not come
we talk about fanaticism this morning
and the question answer session
when a person does things god's way
right down the line that person will be
considered for that
strange and extreme
[Music]
when you tell your professor
you want to do a phd in physics to get
to know god
how is he supposed to understand that
when you order the employer in the bank
and you want to be a monitor or an
accountant why oh i want to develop
character
how is it
the system within which we should live
is not of an earthly origin
you're looking at and looking through
it is the heavily original
when we live within that system we
become aliens to those who live within
the earthly system we have to be of the
world physically but not
mentally and spiritually and
intellectually we must function within
god's system
then we will see the blessings of god
they had a good foundational training
they refused to eat the king's food
the bible says in verse 5 and the king
appointed them a daily provision verse 5
in daniel 1
and the king appointed them a daily
provision of the king's meat of the wine
which is right
sundancing in three years that at the
end thereof they might stand before the
king nebuchadnezzar selected these young
men
they were bright capable
and gave them the royal dying
let me pray again father
continue to tell me what to say to god
in the name of jesus i seriously pray
amen
he gave him
what he consumed
which was the royal diet
but the royal diet of the earth
is not good enough for the child of god
because we have a different royalty
right
let me say it again
daniel had another mishael as azariah
said no
to the best the earth had to offer
because babylon was then the dominant
nation on earth on the earth of the
world of the world of the bible
this unknown
they said here's a recommendation give
us that
pulse to eat water to drink
the experiment was tried after 10 days
the bible says the countenance appears
fairer and fatter in flesh than all the
children eat the portion of the king's
meat or drink his wife
the bible says as to these four children
verse 17 and
[Music]
god gave them knowledge
and skill
in our learning
and wisdom
god gave them
i'm stressing this because i want you to
understand when you stress spiritual
development you never lose
god rewarded them now of course they
studied but god blessed his father to
such a degree the bible says he gave
them knowledge and skill in all learning
and wisdom and daniel had understanding
and all visions and dreams now in my
character personality volume 1 page 34
paragraph 2 the author writes these
words listen carefully
as i slow down
in exact proportion
as the spiritual counter is developed
the intellectual capabilities
[Music]
meditate on that for
five percent
her wording is very precise
almost
mathematically in
exact proportion
as the spiritual character
is developed
or
the intellectual capability
is increased
let me put it differently intellectual
development is a byproduct of spiritual
growth
you know oxygen is a byproduct of
hormones
intellectual development is a by-product
of spiritual growth
and so you harm yourself when you
minimize the word of god because you
have a physics exam
you minimize the art the author of
physics
i'll give it to you again mind
capital and personality
volume 1
page 34
paragraph 2
in exact proportion
as the spiritual character is developed
the intellectual capabilities are
interesting
now as a christian student
you function with this principle in mind
and you do everything
with a spiritual motivation
knowing that god's laws never fail the
byproduct will be a broadly
strengthening deepening of your internet
that's a gift from god to the person who
puts god first
education page 124 paragraph two
isn't careful
as a means of intellectual training
the bible is more effective than any
other book
or all other books combined
you take encyclopedia botanical
encyclopedia americana
encyclopedias of africana
you combine them all
and combine the do not stack up to this
for developing wine
you see this
is the mind of god
do you want to read god's mind
read this
don't want to say woman read this
when you interact with this your mind
comes into contact with the mind of god
now can you imagine
when your mind contacts god's mind god's
mind is not contaminated your mind is
purified amen god's mind is
right action
of course you should study
wrong motive
the pursuit of a piece of paper called a
diploma
must not be the primary reason for
studying it has to be to acquire a
saving transformative knowledge of god
or my name and knowledge that changes
you consistently as your knowledge
increases
because to know god
is to become god
and so my friends my brothers and
sisters
change your motive
amen
god's judgment is based on motive change
your motive
why do i go to the gym not to build
muscles
impress the ladies because a healthy
body
leads to one a healthy mind
then a healthy mind can more effectively
grasp the things of god
are you with me
motive is where god's judgment begins i
am attending the university of cape town
pursuing a degree in uh where's my
friend who was doing geology and then
moved to physics
so that i may understand god
and my faith in god may be strengthened
and as god gave knowledge and skill to
daniel and anaya
and azariah
and god does not change he will
similarly reward the student today
who places him ahead of everything else
the fear of glory
is a beginning of knowledge
and wisdom which also leads to this
glorious realization
a student is in an excellent position
to think of god all day
you go from physics to account are you
with me
you think of god well god says the title
is mine that's my column you know here's
your offering and here is yours
you go from a counter to zoology like
the animals you study in sociology i put
people together every branch of study
except crime
you're in contact with god so all day
from classroom to classroom it is an
interaction with god you are in a
supreme position to interact with god
all day
you go to the library for assignment god
for those of work
let me digress a little bit
the bible's philosophy of work
i told you earlier the purpose of work
originally was to develop capital not to
make
we go back to the original purpose
change your motive
change
and may god
the fundamental foundational basic
motive for which you do
everything
if you do that
god will change your life
god will bless your life because he will
want you to continue on that path
of glorifying him
in everything
that you do
right
action wrong motive
we want to move to right action
right motive
what is the motive the glory
of god
how many of you will say with me father
help me to make your glory
my motive in everything i do can i see
you like that and i'm not joking right
that's that
if you play a friendly game of soccer
you say how
when you know you follow you confess
your sin
when guys play pick-up game basketball
they never found it's you the this is a
christian guy
they never be it's a foul not about you
for our life
even a game must be clear now you say to
yourself now that guy in the book is
extreme
well let me ask you this
when is god not holy
you tell me
what day of the week is god not holding
why does christ not sinners
what secular things are being done in
heaven right now
[Music]
and god will bless us so much
that those around us will come to us
see the most effective form of
evangelism is faithfulness to god
because he blesses so abundantly people
come and ask how come
you don't have you know you don't need a
poster on somebody's face
faithfulness to god
is the most effective form of
evangelistic advertising
how come your children do so well in
school but the primary textbook is the
body
how come there's no divorce among you
people how come you don't go to the
hospital how come none of you is in debt
how come
your crops growing hours die
god
straight
obedience
god first
in everything let me close
i ask you how many of you will put god
as your lord if you said yes
god is the god of confirmation
he gave a dream to pharaoh twice
genesis 41
and joseph explained to pharaoh he was
given trot twice because god wants to
let him know the thing is established or
confirmed of god
now you establish and confirm your
commitment
how many by raising the hand and say to
god father
help me to make your glory
my motive in everything i do can i still
have again
stand up
don't start next week
when she can start
i guarantee you only following god's
word
god will do things in your life
that will shock you
as my eyes closed
give that person time to turn that phone
off
father
thank you very much
for your love for us
you're so eagerly god to fellowship with
us you have placed evidence of yourself
in the entire creation
everywhere we look
where is a blade of grass a leaf a
flower a bird a
stream the feel of the air on our skin
the sun shining in the day the stars
twinkling at night each one of these
things their god is a loving reminder
of a good god amen
father in heaven
jesus prayed in john 17
they are not of the world even as i am
not of the world and that prayer must
cover us
we must function their god
from a heavenly perspective
so that the world fuses astray when
jesus was on the earth and he preached
and he talked and healed the frequent
response was what manner of man is this
we've never seen someone like that when
we live as we ought to live the world
will say the same thing of us what kind
of people are these
[Music]
father in heaven
it's good to perform the right action
but it must be accompanied by the right
monkeys
because ultimately the quality of an act
is decided by the motive behind them
that's why i ask in the name of jesus
their god help us to take seriously the
commitments we've made which was help us
father to make your glory our motive for
everything we do
that kind of thinking does not develop
fully overnight it comes by practice
trial and error but if we're determined
that god we shall rise higher and higher
if that we're thinking
bless your children be god
bless us with your presence in our lives
in everything we do father
let us seek your guidance
your wisdom
because despite all our so-called wisdom
there is a way the seventh right up to
about right
from every angle it looks right but the
end thereof are the ways of death this
major case dear god we need a constant
guidance of the holy ghost
father in heaven
bless us to this end
and bless us so much that our lives on
earth become blessings to others
let our lives be the reason others are
ready to meet you when you come
take a serious day their garden
save us when you come i pray
bless amen
may continue to do a good work for your
glory day father
bless your people wherever they are
i offer this prayer for my heart in
jesus name let god's people say
amen amen